I am a Brit in Florida which means I
apply enormous amounts of sunblock to
stop me going as red as a lobster but
here's something you might not know the
SPF factor on sunblock this 50 here in
this case because I am very pale was
originally meant to be a multiplier the
idea was that if you've earned in 10
minutes without sunblock that would
multiply that by 50 you could manage 500
minutes in burning Sun before you
actually got burned now the thing is
that's not actually true because some
blocks a lot more complicating that it
requires differences depending on skin
tone on all sorts of things on your
personal reaction and unless the
sunblock is broad-spectrum as this is it
doesn't cover against the more harmful
effects the long-term effects not just
turning red so how do they test it well
the way they test is quite wonderful the
FDA in the US for for this the Food and
Drug Administration requires what is
known as an in vivo test meaning it has
to be done on actual live volunteer
which means that someone has presumably
one arm covered in sunblock one arm not
and then they are put under a test Sun
simulator until they burn to see what
happens and while it can technically get
up to a hundred two hundred times
multiplier the FDA requires no more than
50 in Australia no more than thirty
because anything more than that is
considered confusing to people who might
think they can put sunblock on and stay
out all day every day with no risk of
skin cancer so there you go some
protection factor mostly a load of
rubbish although you should still wear
it because otherwise well you're going
to end up like I'm going to look in
there probably a few hours time and that
ah also don't get it in your eyes